it has happened again another difficult
day for america
as we struggle yet again with another
senseless act of gun violence in this
country we're going to take you right to
texas where many parents spent the night
waiting for word on whether their
children survived just put yourself in
those parent shoes for just a second
you're waiting all night to learn if
your child survived after you dropped
them off at school why because a heavily
armed 18 year old male burst through the
doors of an elementary school in uvalde
tony is there
tony i i can't imagine what it's like to
be there on the scene i know i couldn't
sleep last night because i knew we'd be
sitting here again reporting on this
story one more time and i'm so sick and
tired of being sick and tired telling
this type of story
gail i'm with you 100 just listen to the
words we're using this morning 19 dead
children in the school behind me and
that is the second worst school shooting
in american history the second
vivaldi for people who don't know is a
small city it's 15 000 people it's
self-described as the texas of westerns
a pretty town a close-knit town and now
another map another pin on the map
rather of american gun violence
and this is that rare kind of morning
guys it's a it's a day when i don't look
forward to the start of our show and
here's why
according to police just after recess is
when it happened peach slices ham
sandwiches waiting on the school lunch
menu
and that's when 18 year old salvador
ramos walked into rob elementary school
and started going classroom to classroom
shooting students and teachers he was
armed with an ar-15 style rifle also had
high capacity magazines with him
according to police weapons by the way
that he bought legally this very month
on his 18th birthday teachers took
heroic actions sheltering students
locking doors police also responded with
heroism with courage firing on and
ultimately killing the gunman
but not before he carried out the
deadliest school shooting in america
since that last one the sandy hook
massacre the one that made us all say
never again
and now here we are again at least 21
dead 19 of them elementary school-aged
children
parents as you mentioned rushed to the
school yesterday but were turned away
told to gather at a nearby civic center
where they waited on news on whether
their child survived waited on the
results in some cases of dna samples
that would confirm whether their child
was among the 19 children lost
president biden addressed the nation
last night taking all this in calling on
congress to turn our national sorrow
into action
and how many scores of little children
who witnessed what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
where in god's name is our backbone
to have the courage to deal with them
stand up to the lobbies
we're gonna have much more on washington
and the action or inaction there but for
now let's stay in yavaldi with janet
chamberlain who's been here talking to
people janet what are they telling you
this is a community that has shattered
tony it is broken and for the most part
people haven't really been able to
comprehend it yet it's just too fresh
last night this community the houses of
worship they opened their doors and the
people of vivaldi walked through them
sharing unimaginable grief and looking
for some answers of which there were few
the shooter charged through the doors of
uvalde's rob elementary school opening
fire just after 11 30. armed law
enforcement says with an ar-15 assault
rifle high-capacity magazines and a
handgun
before the attack police say the 18 year
old shot his grandmother conflicting
reports this morning on her condition
the gunman then crashed his car near the
school before going in one official
saying he shot at whoever was in his way
his victims second third and fourth
graders and their teachers
numerous agencies swarmed the school
engaging in a shootout with the gunman
who was hiding behind a barricade he was
shot and killed after injuring several
officers
in the aftermath grief-stricken parents
desperate to be reunited with their
children were faced with scenes of chaos
their worst fears compounded by the
unknown just days away from summer break
the tragedy brought the school year to a
sudden and horrific close
my heart was broken today
we're a small community
and we need your prayers to get us
through this
the people of yuvaldi last night
gathering in houses of worship sharing
an unimaginable collective grief only
you know why he did all these things
two of mialina oliveira's children are
high schoolers locked down during the
shooting
she told me one of their younger cousins
is a rob elementary student who was shot
in the arm to all the moms that lost
their babies
i am so sorry
i cannot imagine what they're going
through we also met maria flores who has
lived in uvalde for decades she says
she's friends with the shooter's mom
i've been hearing that he was he was
being bullied
since he was a little boy
you know
[Music]
but we don't know really exactly why
this
thing happened
you think of these things as happening
somewhere else
yeah but you never thought it was going
to happen into your
to your town
it's just
so heartbreaking
heartbreaking indeed and a distinction
this city does not want
now the deadliest school shooting since
the sandy hook massacre and it's just
hard to imagine tony what families are
waking up to this morning after getting
notice last night in overnight you're a
parent i'm a parent i have a 10 year old
a fourth grader
it's hard to get through this morning
janet thank you very much